[موسيقى]
الصين تحتفظ ببيانات ضخمه لجينات شعبها
البالغ عددهم مليارا و400 الف هذه الجينات
تمهد الطريق لكشوف ذات تاثيرات كبيره ولا
سيما في رعايه الصحيه والاقتصاد والدفاع
الوطني والسلامه الجيولوجيه اذ يؤكد
العلماء فائده الماده الوراثيه لهذه
الجينات في دراسه الامراض وعلاجها اضافه
الى توفيرها فهما افضل لكيفيه تكون العيوب
الخلقيه لدى البشر لكن بكين تصر على
تحفظها على تقاسم هذه البيانات على الرغم
من حاجتها الى تعاون دولي لتحقيق الهدف
المرجو من جمعها وتريد ان يكون لها اليد
الطول في حمايه جينات شعبها في ظل تركيز
الحكومه المتزايده على الامن القومي
للبلاد وهنا دفعها الى فرد قيود صارمه على
الوصول الى الموارد الوراثيه البشريه وسنت
لذلك عام 2019 قوانين ضمن ما يسمى لوائح
اوليه تمنع الكيانات الاجنبيه من جمع
الموارد الوراثيه الصينيه لمنع استخدامها
في اغراض تجاريه نموذجيه مثل خدمات تسلسل
الجيني
هل تشارك الدول الغربيه اخرين في بياناتها
كثير من الدول لديها قوانين تنظم استخدام
البيانات الجينيه ونقها الى ان القليل
منها لديه قواعد صارمه مثل قوانين الصين
فبريطانيا مثلا تجمع بيانات جينيه مجهوله
المصدر لسكانها وتقدمها الى الباحثين
راغبين في تحقيق كشوف علميه جديده وكذلك
امريكا توفر البيانات للعلماء المؤهلين في
العالم ايمانا منها بان تقاسمها يمكن ان
يسرع الكشف العلمي ويعود بالفائده على
المجتمع العلمي الاوس